[Music]
hey folks welcome to the ninth
livestream on the Dark Horse podcast i'm
brett weinstein i am sitting with dr.
heather hang to my right and we are
going to discuss a number of things
today
some of them directly related to the
coab in nineteen crisis but many of them
taking a step back and looking at a
bigger picture we thought we would start
today we have had a history of starting
with Corrections I don't have any
explicit correction this is this time
but I did have an addendum that I wanted
to make to something I said last time
the addendum is this I said on the last
live stream I in fact made a not so
polite request of our female viewers
that they I think the way I put it was
stop sleeping with [ __ ] and the idea
was that that would make the world a
better place and I still believe that
that is a an important ingredient but it
was quite incomplete the fact is there
is a another side to that coin which
involves men ceasing to focus on getting
lucky without commitment that would also
make the world a better place
so at some level this delves into a
discussion that you and I have had among
other places we had a discussion related
to this on the Joe Rogan program and it
involves two main ingredients basically
in some it is a renegotiation of the
deal between male and female something
an alternative to the naive proposal
that we see in many places that
effectively men and women are the same
but for some kind of patriarchal force
that imposes difference on us and that's
obviously evolutionary nonsense you said
it with a straight face though well done
I did actually I do a lot of the most
hilarious stuff with a perfectly
straight face I've noticed I have begun
on Twitter to end my ironic comments
with an emoji because I'm not really an
emoji kind of guy so people can tell I'm
kidding if there's an emoji anyway the
point is it is time
because so much about our situation has
changed from the historical past where
our original deal between male and
female were was negotiated it is time
for us to revise that deal in light of
the modern world that we live in how we
do that is a more complex matter so it's
it's specifically what you're alluding
to is some of the novelty of our modern
existence novelty which is changing at
an ever more rapid rate something that
we have come to call hyper novelty and
indeed this is exactly the focus broadly
of our book which will be out in about a
year
so hunter-gatherers guide to the 21st
century explores how it is that
evolutionary beings with a greater
ability to respond quickly to change
than any other species that's out there
us with more in the software realm that
is driving us than in the hardware than
is true of any other species how it is
that we can persist and indeed be robust
in the face of such change so one of one
of the chapters I think last time we
alluded to one of the chapters being
about food one of them is also about sex
and gender another is about relationship
and parenting and indeed obviously a
piece of advice that says you know half
the population you need to do this
misses the other half of the population
and for almost all such prescriptions
there is something that that both men
and women could be doing yeah so for
those who are scratching their heads
over what we mean by novelty and what
effect it might be having just take the
following example the fact of
technological birth control that is
highly effective changes the the
spectrum of risks associated with sex
dramatically especially for women who in
a past era without reliable birth
control would have faced a situation
where if they had sex with a guy who was
not ready to commit or in a position to
commit could easily end up stuck with a
child that they needed to raise alone so
women
for were psychologically constructed to
resist that hazard at all costs to be
less interested women are
psychologically constructed as you say
to be less interested in casual sex and
to be more coy to use one of the words
that tends to be bandied about in
evolutionary circles so now that women
are in a position to control their their
reproductive output through
technological means that spectrum of
hazards is altered but what isn't
inherently altered is the psychology of
male and female that goes along with the
sexual game as it were and so figuring
out how to retool our our psychological
apparatus in as much as possible for
modern realities and how to understand
ourselves as consequences of evolution
in an environment we no longer live in
because to some extent some of these
things are not psychologically easily
altered and therefore coming to grips
with what we've been handed and figuring
out how to marshal it usefully in the
modern era is kind of the key to being a
modern human ok before we leave this
topic there let's not leave with the
impression that being an [ __ ] is the
male strategy in human history right as
as we've talked about elsewhere and
we'll continue to talk about we view it
as there being effectively three
strategies three male strategies that
have been effective although at least
one of them is totally horrific right so
one strategy that males have used to get
their genes into the future has been
forced copulation or rape and no one
condones that it's not okay but the
other two one of them is this you know
broadly speaking like ad strategy the
[ __ ] strategy to use your language
from before they'll love them and leave
them you know all of this looking for
one-night stands looking for
opportunities to impregnate someone and
then have nothing to do with the
resulting child but of course as we know
emerging as most of the viewers and
listeners here do from from cultures in
which monogamy is a cultural norm and
for most of us a cultural value there is
a third male strategy which is
lovely and which very I don't know that
anyone views it as the [ __ ] strategy
which is a monogamous pair bonded
investing in children and helping to
raise children strategy yes and it
eventually produces technical help
capable of mailing a complex podcast
like this one yes so totally unforeseen
consequences of the delightful sort
we've got him laughing back there now so
that's good our technical help is
laughing but I would say actually maybe
we can move in the direction of a useful
outgrowth of this kind of viewpoint
which is being an [ __ ] is a male
strategy so long as there is a niche for
it
at the point that it is no longer a
productive strategy it won't be one
anymore and so the whole reason that I
gave the obnoxious piece of advice that
I gave in the last live stream I don't
think it's about just minutes oh it's
deliberately of not okay so I'm fine
with its level of obnoxiousness but
anyway the point is look we are all
creating a landscape of opportunities
for our competitors and our partners and
creating a better landscape that rewards
strategies that we want to see and
doesn't provide sustenance to strategies
we don't want to see is exactly what we
ought to be doing and amazingly enough
it's the very same thing we're trying to
do with this virus that has spread
across the world as we're trying to deny
it
opportunities and to effectively Corral
it by not giving it the conduits between
here and there and you and me and all of
that that it seems to have found that's
right we would like to deny all their
basest instincts and for a virus it's
entirely basest instincts and so we need
to corral it into being less virulent
and having and you know having an ro of
less than one and I'm not familiar
enough for the R sub T that you that you
were talking about last time but if it's
if the math is similar you know all of
these methods of transmission we want to
reduce them and and create pathogens
that we can live with as opposed to only
die with great pathogens we can live
with to the extent we've got them and
not create pathways for pathogens we
can't live with and as long as we're on
the topic I would just point out same
logic applies economically and
politically you see the strategies for
which there is a niche it makes no sense
to get overly upset about whatever
critter happens to have exploited and
innovated in that niche if you don't
want to see the behavior for example
political corruption it has to be more
costly than it is beneficial at the
point political corruption is more
costly than it is profitable you won't
see it so if you want to if you want to
prevent it that's the way to do it good
all right on to our next topic I think
you were going to launch us here yeah I
was looking we have done a lot of
troubleshooting this week so I am maybe
not as ensconced in some of the
literature that has emerged as I might
have been but I have seen some comments
that caused me to think there was a
place we need to return to and in
particular I saw several comments one
that struggled my caught my attention
very precipitously was a comment by
somebody who had had Kovac 19 had
recovered or was in the process of
recovering still finds themselves very
compromised in terms of their
respiration and saw my comment that
effectively the damage done by these
pathogens gives a person a giant shove
in the direction of death and he was
lamenting the fact that maybe this meant
that something very serious had occurred
from which there was no escape its
emerges from the conversation about the
the binary idea that you're dead or your
perfect is is wrongheaded and we should
be adding nuance to that conversation
yeah or I would say you are sick or you
are recovered is the place where the
binary is particularly misleading so let
me step back a second and say that what
we're about to talk about emerges from
work I did a long time ago on
telomere some of you will be aware of
that work it was discussed extensively
on Eric his podcast the portal episode
19 we talked about the telomere work and
what it had been and we're not gonna go
deeply into it here but I will say that
the basic model involves the fact that
on the ends of our chromosomes you'll
remember from wherever you learned about
chromosomes that our chromosomes are
linear they are a line of genetic
information and at the ends both ends of
a chromosome you have a repetitive
sequence that it's not a gene it doesn't
contain information about how to make a
protein or anything like that it is just
a repetitive sequence that has a
particular number of repeats that's
called the telomere and that number of
repeats it happens in creatures like us
decreases every time a cell divides now
cells basically have three reasons to
divide they could divide as a result of
your growth you're getting bigger you
need more cells than you've got it could
divide as a result of maintenance where
some cell is replaced by another cell
that does the same job or it could
happen when you have a need for repair
so if you've damaged something and you
need to grow more you know skin or
whatever to fill in a cut that you have
all of those things will cause cells to
divide and in almost all of your tissues
a loss of telomere so that loss of
telomeres what I worked on and the
upshot of that work is that the telomere
loss which appears to be associated with
what we colloquially call aging what we
scientifically call senescence that is
the degradation of your function with
age that that loss appears to be an
adaptation and the adaptation is
preventing tumors so we have growths
where a cell has gotten has become
broken as a result of mutation some of
those ways that a cell can become broken
would cause it to reproduce without
reason if it reproduces with that reason
long enough almost no matter where in
your body a cell is
will crowd out something that you're
depending on and you'll die so you know
creature like us that might have 30
trillion cells every one of those cells
that is capable of replacing itself is
also capable of duplicating too much and
many of them can kill you if they do it
so a counter that limits the number of
times a cell can divide is a protective
mechanism it would appear and the
downside of it is it limits the amount
of maintenance and repair you can do
which causes us ultimately to have to
die of the failure of an organ so we
sort of exist between these two hazards
cancer on the one hand and organ failure
on the other and these things are
balanced and if everything goes well you
live a very long time as a result of
that balance but nobody gets past 120
120 years in under 20 years yeah and
doesn't mean nobody will ever get past
120 but the your prospects get so bad
late in that sequence that you know
somebody live to a hundred and twenty
three and you know maybe they have but
it you know it doesn't say that we're on
the brink of something new it just you
know a large population you'll get more
outliers based just just to be clear
you're stipulating very clearly and
strongly that there is not going to be a
panacea for the the outer edges of the
human lifespan that we're not going to
end up living to two hundred or a
thousand or otherwise breaking this
barrier of approximately 120 years is
how long humans at the outside can
expect to be able to learn to be able to
live yeah I don't want to say it
couldn't happen I mean that's the kind
of thing you know if you start speaking
that way you you know looking like a
fool but in this case the the things
that are arrayed against such an effort
are so powerful long-standing widespread
that I do not expect us ever to defeat
human aging as people say and I would
just point out even if we've figured out
how to do it for the body you've got a
problem with the way the brain functions
and the failure of the brain has very
little to do with the inability of cells
to replace themselves because the cells
in quest
our neurons and a neuron may be
connected to a thousand other neurons so
it's not the number of cells you have
doing brain work it's the connectivity
of them and so how that connectivity is
deployed and lost over time and all of
that that's a whole different problem
and we really have no idea how to even
begin to revise the brain to to make you
live longer in terms of your body we
actually know right now how to get you
to live longer than you will currently
live and it involves reducing damage
right this actually works we are but
you're not talking about extending the
life of the body beyond 120 years right
that is a fool's errand I would say at
this point we can make you younger
longer and we can make you healthier and
we can get you closer to 120 it involves
reducing the amount of damage that you
suffer and that has implications for
this commenter who was wondering
grappling with the implications of the
disease that he is faced and a lot
beyond that so what I was hoping to get
to was I should say we have been living
with this model of telomere based aging
since nineteen ninety eight or nine yeah
it sounds right something like that so
that means that we because we believe
that this is a correct description of
why the human body grows feeble and
inefficient with age not humans all
mammals birds complex animals as a whole
living with this model we also have to
grapple with the everyday questions of
what to do and what not to do and so
anyway we've learned a lot about what
it's like to look through that lens and
I think what I'm hoping is that people
will move past just seeing the downside
of this oh my god I've suffered damage
and start thinking about the upside of
understanding this so how to describe it
imagine for a second that the grave is a
place we
something like a magnetic pole and that
that magnetic pole is very weak when you
are young and healthy and it grows
stronger the older you get right the
grave is pulling you towards it and if
you suffer some kind of body wide damage
you get a giant shove in the direction
of that magnet doesn't necessarily push
you close enough to the magnet that you
fall into the grave but it pushes you
closer to it now that leaves you with an
opportunity which is well I'm not happy
that I'm closer to that magnet than I
was but I can take actions so that my
motion in that direction slows down to
compensate and this has many
implications for how one views health I
must say I have been scratching my head
for decades now wondering why we look at
infectious disease the way we appear to
look at it where you know we treat
infectious disease almost as if well I
was sick and it cost me two weeks now
I'm better I'm gonna pick up right where
I was rather than gee I wonder how much
damage that did I wonder how much of my
total potential living I lost the
capacity for and odd I not avoid illness
with the expectation that each of these
things is actually shoving you in a
direction you really don't want to go so
there's a there's a balancing game to be
played at all of these interfaces of
course trade-offs everywhere but one
thing that your little soliloquy there
just brought up for me is you and I and
we have for our children even more so
avoid prescription and over-the-counter
drugs absolutely as much as possible
alright we're not feeling well it takes
it takes a bit to get us to take an
aspirin or a Tylenol and for a long time
emerging from your work at teyla mary's
cancer and senescence we avoid the
NSAIDs the non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory light
ibuprofen a motrin and such completely
for reasons that you can go into and
another timer or now but avoiding
avoiding drugs that might reduce
symptoms when the symptoms themselves
might cause damage that would also
accelerate aging means that there is
something of a trade-off and so it is
also true that fever for instance fever
and up in the case of a lot of
infectious diseases is not actually the
disease but your body's response your
body's adaptive response as by now I
think many many people have heard this
but but when when for instance an SE and
Williams book why we get sick why we get
sick came out in the mid 90s sometime
that was one of the claims in it and it
was it was considered bold and new and
you know may be wrong even at that point
it's not that no fever is the is the
pathogens work but often it is the
body's adaptive response so an adaptive
response which can kill you
which can kill you absolutely but
lowering a fever
in such cases means getting in the way
of your body's adaptive response which
is basically at you know at a very rough
very granular level raising your body's
temperature above the realm in which the
pathogen can survive and reproduce
easily for a long enough time to kill
the pathogen and hopefully a short
enough time that it doesn't kill you so
one you know should not simply take
fever reducers at the first sign of
fever because the fever makes you
uncomfortable because a very good chance
that the fever is actually your body
doing your bidding on the other hand
fever does damage so you know there's
trade-offs and all of these there are as
long as we're here I guess it's getting
pretty late it's a little past 3:30 here
on the Pacific coast so the kids are
already in bed we can talk about the
difficult stuff avoiding drugs is not a
blanket prescription and I would just I
want to be careful here you can straddle
the gap a little
with respect to what you take and I
would say it's a pharmaceutical and
over-the-counter drugs yes so let's talk
about before we understood any of this
damage model of aging we did a lot of
traveling in the tropics and we ended up
taking the kinds of drugs that one takes
in the pursuit of tropical field work we
took cipro which deals with pathogens
that it's Adrienne God it's a
broad-spectrum antibiotic that is
especially good for GI I think you're an
area tract and skin infections yeah and
it turns out you know what it damages
tendons and I believe ligaments yes so
this this may be another you know a
topic for another time but just asterisk
I feel certain and a few doctors to whom
I've mentioned it feel pretty compelled
that when I ruptured my Achilles tendon
in mmm what was it 2013 playing ultimate
with bunch of our students that that
that rupture was almost certainly at
least related in part to my having taken
cipro a fair bit in my 20s well done
field work and I busted an ACL playing
ultimate some years before that of
course the common theme there is
Ultimate Frisbee but history which is I
stopped playing at this point because
it's obviously a bit dangerous but in
any case we learned too late that the
cipro that we had taken thinking that it
was pretty close to cost-free just
simply wasn't um we have learned similar
things about benadryl benadryl function
is differently but it appears to be
closely related to dementia and a
cumulative quantity of benadryl taken
over a lifetime is somewhat predictive
of future dementia so that's a case
where again we've learned that some drug
that we thought was safe just simply
wasn't erythromycin does heart damage
Natick yep and seds do heart damage so
the bottom line is synthetic stuff
carries a fairly strong risk
of doing some kind of damage that you're
not aware of and at some level it's
pushing you in the direction of that
magnet of the grave so what about the
woowoo seeming suggestion that
botanicals are safer that drugs derived
from botanicals you know aspirin that
you can take now is certainly derived is
synthesized in a lab but it's derived
from willow bark and you and I prefer
aspirin when we feel like we need to
take such a such a thing yeah what I
mean I'm just I'm gonna feed you the
question right so you know why why
aspirin and not Advil well let's just
first say there's nothing magical about
botanicals there's certainly innumerable
toxins created by plants generally
they're what's called secondary
compounds which means they are compounds
that have no value in the plant they're
not part of some pathway but they're
there to dissuade herbivores from eating
the plant they're there as toxins and in
fact almost all of our medicines that we
get from plants are toxins as produced
by the plant and what we do the magic of
these medicines is in titration and that
is to say so here's the quick and dirty
logic the plants are looking for ways to
dissuade their herbivores many of whom
are mammals from eating their leaves
generally so they load the leaves up
with toxins well what's a toxin a toxin
is something that disrupts the function
of the physiology of the animal that
would be eating it how do you disrupt
the function well an animal is a highly
complex creature with you know hundreds
of chemical pathways in it disrupting
any one of them will reduce its function
and so in effect plants have been
exploring animal physiology by creating
compounds that happened to disrupt some
animals or vivir e and then amplifying
their quantity modifying their shape
whatever it is that makes them more
effective we can now borrow these
molecules that interfere with animal
physiology and if you are if your own
pathway is poorly regulated in the down
direction some plant is out
they're amplifying that pathway and we
can borrow that compound we can amplify
that pathway to the key being titration
the amount so so where as sucking air
and willow bark doesn't allow you to
control how much what is it cell silic
acid you're getting a lab can control
exactly how much you're getting and you
can know that you're taking the exact
same amount as you did the last time you
can hope I mean we do a bad job of this
the bottle says you know take two of
these every four hours for an adult but
adults vary a wide degree in size so it
doesn't make a whole lot of sense and we
know historically that massive errors
have been made and again this is from an
earlier live stream we did but there's
evidence that the Spanish flu pandemic
was made vastly worse by aspirin why
because they gave quantities that would
now be considered insane so that very
compound that is therapeutic and useful
is dangerous in high enough quantities
so I want to partially answer the
question I posed to you something I
didn't hear in your answer yet which is
that we have we or our relatives the
herbivores who might be chewing on the
plants that have created the secondary
compounds in order to deter those
herbivores have a long evolutionary
history with things that this with the
secondary compounds in plants and that's
not to say that some of them couldn't
kill us outright and some of them might
kill us over time and some of them might
create hallucinations and some of us
might like those and some of us might
not but in general we have an
evolutionary history with them and so
once again we've we've gone full circle
back to this concept of novelty of hyper
novelty that something that is totally
new that's been synthesized in the lab
is something to be more wary of because
of the complete lack of evolutionary
history that we have with it for exactly
the same reason that SARS Cove 2 is
proving to be so intractable so
difficult to figure on so many different
domains right it's because six months
ago we'd never met it and it had never
met us and so it is it is figuring us
out right now with not nearly as many of
the tools as we have to figure it out
but we also don't have all of its tools
so we
we're coming at each other with
different tool kits and we are hoping to
figure out what it's doing but we are
we're flying blind at some level and the
same is true when we get handed a new
drug like cipro or erythromycin or you
know any number of these things that are
as far as I know completely synthetic
and told it'll be fine
we know that it targets this system in
the body you know well are there are
there are there long term health effects
no you can't know that
you know the R&D maybe it was a few
years if if that and it doesn't there's
there's no way that we're gonna spend 30
50 80 years on R&D plus it's too noisy
we would would be very very difficult to
know what the toxic effects of some of
these drugs were whereas when a drug
like while digitalis comes out which is
based on which is derived from is oh
it's when when digital starts being used
might for for heart conditions my
thought is knowing nothing else
I trust that more than I do the drug
that is entirely synthetic that is that
we are being told does the same thing
because we have or our close relatives
have an evolutionary history with did
you tell us that's true I should say
erythromycin will certainly have been
originally derived from I don't know if
it was a fungus or bacteria probably a
fungus but I'm sure it's made in a lab
now but in any case there is something
and it has to be it's a this is a
question it's an art not a science
figuring out what molecules are less
likely to be destructive of you than
others is it's a navigable landscape and
so for example benadryl widely used as a
sleep aid even though it's an
antihistamine
which is a basically a chemical
inhibitor of an immune pathway histamine
reaction it is used it happens to be
soporific it induces sleep and so
actually we ended up using that in the
tropics where sometimes you're in very
uncomfortable circumstances covered in
bike covered bites and it's hot and
anyway
knock yourself out on the other hand we
find out decades later it has it's a
contributing factor to dementia what
about something like melatonin is
melatonin likely to be safer than
benadryl well I would argue it's likely
to be safer because we know what sort of
molecule it is and why it's interfering
in a way that is likely you can harm
yourself but what you're liable to do is
harm your sleep-wake cycle rather than
contribute to some other pathway why can
we say that because melatonin is a
chemical that we produce ourselves it's
a chemical involved in the way our sleep
cycle is regulated and so we are
effectively hacking our sleep cycle by
utilizing a molecule by introducing it
artificially at a moment when we want to
go to sleep but that molecule being one
that we make is also one that we're
capable of taking apart safely likewise
and again we wouldn't be discussing this
if the children were still awake none of
them are none of them are if you take
something like hallucinogenic mushrooms
right hallucinogenic mushrooms are a
molecule that a fungus is producing to
dissuade herbivores we argue in our book
that it is psychologically dissuading
those herbivores rather than poisoning
them it is horrifying them and to the
extent that even then with stories to
tell or without the language to tell
them right and so to the extent that the
experience that is understandably very
frightening to you know a deer that ate
the wrong mushroom might be something
that you could utilize in order to you
know cross certain boundaries of
consciousness that are otherwise not
accessible to you that that is not
likely to be it's not designed by the
plant as apposite oxen it's designed for
a psychological effect and using it to
hack your own psychology is liable to be
much safer than let's say a designer
drug that
fears with brain function in some
unknown way and causes yes some effects
but what byproducts yeah
so mushrooms versus LSD so and yet LSD
is derived from ergo which is a fungus
but and it's and it's usually available
form it's been synthesized and had all
sorts of things added to it as well yeah
and they're a whole lot of these
compounds that are not fully synthetic
right all right so where we were headed
with this is what should a person who
has become sick with let's say Kovac 19
had a severe case and then recovered how
should they feel and what should they
think and again borrowing from our own
experience trying to navigate this
question of what do i do as a creature
with a fixed amount of repair and
maintenance that I can do over a
lifetime which I end up spending
arbitrarily if somebody doesn't wash
their hands and I get the flu from them
and I've been damaged when I've
recovered I don't assume oh I got away
with it you know I was sidelined for a
week but I'm back I think damn that's a
real setback and I think as you get more
comfortable with this model what you
realize is that this is like a bank
account a bank account that you're
spending for you you know at the point
that you're wise enough to think this
way you're already in adults you're not
spending it on growth it's maintenance
and repair anything you spend on repair
is not left from maintenance you're
borrowing that from your future
so tuning in on those things which are
creating damage and learning to avoid
them so that you have more to spend on
maintenance effectively you can maintain
yourself in a more youthful way longer
into the future is just simply the smart
thing to do and so at the risk of
getting a bit personal I wanted to talk
about some things that I have discovered
far too late about myself that I think
are useful but I wish I had known them
far earlier in my life so the first one
has to do
I had a case of asthma that dogged me
for my whole adult life and we had tried
virtually everything to address it we
had gotten all kinds of advice from
doctors we had been told I was allergic
to caps which I probably am but not all
cats right cats differ we've been told
that it was you know dust mites in the
bedding we've been told all kinds of
things and we'd done all kinds of stuff
we actually took the forced air heating
system out of our prior house with the
thought that it was transmitting dust
that I was sensitive to and eventually
when none of this really worked
I noticed somewhere on the internet that
people were reporting that they were
having a reaction to gluten that was
causing respiratory illness basically
causing asthma and my thought at the
time was no way at the time I really
wasn't even a believer in gluten
allergies as a widespread problem but
since we had tried everything else
I decided what could it hurt to take
gluten out of my diet and see what
happened and it didn't happen right away
it took a couple of weeks but if I
eliminated gluten from my diet for a
couple of weeks my symptoms got entirely
better and then if I reintroduced it to
my diet they went right back to where
they were and I went to the doctor and I
said can you test me for gluten allergy
it actually came back negative and I
said what does that mean the doctor said
actually we see that a fair amount
people are negative but they you should
go with wool if it's effective to
limonade it from your diet ignore the
test what I later discovered a great
doctor yeah what a rare and great doctor
doctor response he was great doctor dr.
Scott thank you
so what I discovered later was that
probably in my case it's not gluten
what I discovered quite accidentally was
that my sensitivity is to wheat there's
some molecule in wheat now the only way
I can avoid wheat is to you know if I go
into a restaurant I say have a wheat
allergy they scratch their heads if I
say I have a gluten allergy many of them
know what to do so I talk as a
I have a lutein allergy but I'm almost
certain that I do not both on the basis
that the test comes back negative and on
the basis that Bombay Sapphire gin is
certified gluten-free and yet I have the
same reaction to it that I have if
somebody gives me soy sauce with wheat
in it for example so what is always
we've inadvertently run a number of
natural experiments where sometimes you
know and sometimes you don't but I do
know that you've gotten something that
you've ingested something that has wheat
in it and if I know and you don't it's
already happened
I don't tell you and I didn't at first
because you and I both were interested
to know if there was any chance that you
were tricking yourself no you were
fooling your sufferer and no you're not
yep you get that you get the symptoms
every time and when we were on study
abroad in Ecuador where it's very
difficult to avoid wheat completely
there's just not enough awareness of
where wheat is and isn't so you end up
getting dosed with wheat every so often
just that of course and we had two other
two students as well who are very
sensitive to the three of you yes the
three of us would suddenly have the same
reaction we'd had some meal together
somewhere and suddenly we're all like oh
there it is again
right so anyway all of these things
begin to tell a pretty clear story about
in my case wheat exposure even tiny
amounts of weed exposure are sufficient
to trigger it but the bottom line is my
lung symptoms cleared up I would say 90%
if I just simply was completely
religious about keeping wheat out of my
diet and that was you know enough I'd
basically it reduced my lung symptoms to
a absolutely minor annoyance what I have
found more recently is that the minor
annoyance actually goes away if I
maintain my weight below a hundred and
seventy pounds right so that's not an
easy number for me to hit but if I can
get below a hundred and seventy pounds I
can go all winter with no cough
whatsoever right and so my suspicion is
this has to do we
some kind of cytokine storm if you
basically an inflammation issue that was
body wide in the presence of wheat was
greatly reduced by the elimination of
wheat and can be further reduced by my
maintaining my weight at that level so
the advice I would give is you need to
figure out you know this may not apply
to you at all the things that work for
me but you are a system that you can
tune into you can figure out what in
your diet might be triggering you by
eliminating those things that are
candidates and seeing what changes and
then introducing them back in and seeing
if you revert one thing you haven't said
though is that for many of these
allergies I don't think we have time
today to talk about what we think why we
think that there is such an increase in
particular kinds of these things but
that for many of them
you can't just reduce the amount of say
wheat in your diet to ninety-five five
percent of what it used to be which is
honestly what most people do when they
go on what they claim our elimination
diets they end up having a little bit of
something and because their symptoms
haven't cleared yet anyway they don't
notice and so you know people will say
well I tried an elimination diet and
nothing got better so I'm pretty sure
it's not any of those things that I
eliminated but you really have to go to
zero to zero to completely clear it from
your system or else your body is going
to be if it is allergic it's going to be
sending up a response you need to get to
zero you need to figure out where there
might be a leak that you're not aware of
like soy sauce until you get the idea
that for some reason soy sauce is almost
almost ubiquitously has wheat unless you
specifically sourced wheat free soy
sauce you know you've got to eliminate
all of those things and then you've got
to give it time for whatever cytokine
pathway has been triggered to to turn
itself off in order to detect what your
physiology is like on the other side and
you may well find wheats not an issue
for you but something else might be and
anyway that the larger point really
isn't about wheat it's about
signal-to-noise ratios we live in a very
we are complex critters our diets are
more complex than any ancestor would
have faced that is to say they source
things from all over the world one
person might be fine with this
ingredient you may not be fine you don't
know but you have to get the noise level
down so you can begin to detect the
signals once you detect the signals then
the point is look the game is simple you
want to reduce damage if you do damage
to one organ over and over and over
again if you damage your liver every
night with too much alcohol
well then eventually you might push your
liver towards the grave if your liver
dies that's cirrhosis of the liver right
that's what happens your liver is dying
because it's exhausted a lifetime's
worth of repair capacity and you can die
from that if you can manage to keep your
liver functional then you won't die of
that particular malady but if you had a
job that forced you to repetitively do
one thing over and over again if you
were using a pickaxe mining coal or
something like that your arms would age
faster than the rest of you because
their capacity to maintain themselves
would be exhausted early now you're
probably not going to die of feeble arms
but you'll have arthritis and it will be
crippling to you so realizing that
damages the enemy the damage is another
way of speaking about the magnetic force
of the grave and that you know to this
person who made the comment about the
case of kovat 19 he just recovered from
yep you probably did get a shove towards
the grave how big a shove nobody knows
yet I really don't think we have the
data on what the damage looks like for
various levels of symptomatology for
this disease maybe it was a big shove
maybe not but irrespective of what sort
of shove it was the right response is to
tune in to what kinds of damage you're
doing all the time and to reduce them so
that your rate of progress in that
direction slows down and that you can
definitely do so don't despair chin up
yes it was a show of towards the grave
but we all get them and you got unlucky
this time
it's now time to take charge of your
level of damage and reduce it very good
all right are we yeah you other somewhat
disconnected topics that we just wanted
to to talk about briefly good uh 45
minutes all right
it's a bit of a follow-up to the
discussion that we had about the MIT
subway study last time with regard to
routes of transmission the subway study
is those of you who tuned in last time
we'll remember suggested that Subway's
being quite packed even after shelter
and place orders came down in New York
City seemed to be a major route of
transmission for SARS Cove - in New York
City well there's a paper out called
indoor transmission of SARS Cove to key
on a tall 2020 which suggests that
indoor transmission is far more likely
than outdoor and at one level that seems
completely obvious and yet also the
shutting down of parks and of beaches
and of skate parks and the admonition
that when people are walking outside
they have to be wearing masks all strike
me as suggestive that people do not have
a nuanced enough model here that you
know this stays six feet away from one
another has from the beginning struck me
as an insane number it's clearly not
enough but it's better than nothing and
the you know mask yourself at all times
well we don't mask ourselves in our
house in case some virus happens to come
in the window so you know there there is
there are going to be nuances with
regard to what is the best best move so
from the discussion of this paper again
kion and all 2020 here's a direct quote
our study does not rule out outdoor
transmission of the virus however among
our 7324 identified cases in China with
sufficient descriptions only one outdoor
outbreak involving two cases occurred in
a village in shanku Henan a 27 year old
man had a conversation outdoors than
individual who returned from woo
on the 25th of January and had the onset
of symptoms several days later so they
find through a combination of hospital
records and being able to track where
people are and and what the method of
community transmission appears to have
been to find that being outdoors is
actually somewhat protective
yeah they don't use that language but
but I will I will go ahead and say being
outdoors if you're going to engage with
other people at all it's going to be far
more protective so for instance in
Portland where we live there is now one
as far as I know weekly farmers market
open and there's all sorts of alarm that
I'm seeing about the idea of farmers
market because farmers markets are
obviously often crowded places with lots
of people exchanging you know money and
produce and such liberals go to them so
there's lots of hugging oh and it's far
more likely if people are being safe if
people are keeping some distance but
mostly if people are masked and if
especially if we can reduce the exchange
of actual bills right which is something
that happens more at farmers markets
than in grocery stores at this point
whew far very few people pay with cash
at a grocery store but many people
including me pay with cash at farmers
market the farmers market controlling
for those other factors is actually
likely to be safer it's likely to be far
safer to shop in such a situation and I
will just say that while this paper
looked compelling to me it is consistent
with the lead authors results from a
paper from ten years ago which was
called natural ventilation for reducing
air borne infection in hospitals which I
think I may have referenced in our very
first live stream here in which he found
he want ventilation to decrease
pathogens spread but mechanical
ventilation doesn't do anything close to
the job of basically opening up windows
on either side of a room mm-hmm so first
of all I just have to say how is it that
nobody has used routes of transmission
it's a marvelous pun for the title of a
paper and nobody's used two routes of
transmit subways routes of transmission
I mean it
right there but I don't know how how to
say this next thing to people I guess
I'm responding in some sense to one
comment I happen to catch to our last
livestream which had to do somebody
asserted that beaches have to remain
closed because there are no lifeguards
to save drowning people and they then
asserted closing beaches is good
governments and on the one hand I do get
it on the other hand I think one of the
many really important lessons of the
kovat 19 disaster is there are no adults
that apparatus that is supposed to be
protecting us has failed miserably at so
many different levels simultaneously
that means we have to do our own job of
protecting ourselves I do believe in
good governance I really believe it is
possible and that it is necessary but I
also must say that to the extent that
people fear the nanny state
I think this epidemic is showing us
exactly what there is to be feared the
government telling you don't go out into
nature at a point when your instinct
might be to do just that and then the
discovery later on that in fact that
might have even been epidemiologically
the right thing to do this is telling us
something important the fact is you
don't need a lifeguard to enjoy a beach
you don't need a lifeguard
to go swimming at the beach you do need
to know what it means to swim at your
own risk and the fact is this is
dangerous you and I have had incidents
in our past where we have nearly drowned
as a result of things we didn't
understand about the places where we
were encountering water it's not a small
matter on the other hand if you
recognize that beaches existed before
lifeguards did people swam at them you
don't have to go swimming to go to the
beach but if you're gonna go to the
beach and you feel like you should go
swimming figure out how it is that
you enter the water such that you
discover the hazard before it gets the
better of you we are living in
unprecedented times and it is as if we
have all gone to a different
nation-state with different levels of
governance in place so when we wouldn't
when I would run study abroad for many
years and we ran our study abroad in
2015-16 to Ecuador for 11 weeks I and
then we would always spend a lot of time
in advance talking with the students
about the nature of risk their
relationship with risk and what it means
that we are now we are now going to be
travelling not only to other people's
homes another person in other people's
home countries and homes but also to
places that have not been made safe by
lawyers and this is something that most
Americans most people in weird again
that acronym Western educated
industrialized rich democratic company
countries most people in weird countries
who haven't traveled much can't really
grok they walk around with sidewalks
that are perfectly flat and smooth and
with everything watched out for them and
when something goes wrong they think
someone else here is to blame whereas if
you travel widely or right now if you
want to go to a beach you should be
expected to be able to take the
consequences for doing so when there are
there have to be lower safety standards
in place so I want to not correct but
clarify one thing there I think people
are gonna find your your comment about
lawyers completely mysterious okay so
this is internal code it is not that we
are suggesting that lawyers are these
angels come to make places safer in fact
it is they're very defects of character
the fact that they are constantly
looking for people to sue that results
in them making environments safer than
they would otherwise be
by taking people to court you know your
dad's probably watching yeah he probably
is but in any case that is the
connection between lawyers and safety
and the point is not you know this can
be a very good
the fact is there's a phenomenon I'm
about to get in in cultural trouble here
but when we have traveled to Latin
America there is a phenomenon that we
refer to and we have spent a lot of time
talking to students about it before they
get there there's nothing pejorative
about this but there's a thing called a
gringo trap a gringo trap is like a hole
in the side cavernous hole into which
you can look if you stop it's the bottom
rebar sticking out of it right and the
thing is in Latin America shingles and
I'm sure it's not everywhere in Latin
America but in many places in Latin
America as a result of economic
disparities such things are much more
common on the street you would never
find such a thing on a major American
Street without you know cones and things
that would warn you about it so a gringo
can find themselves falling into such a
thing because they've grown up in a
world that's that's so safe and you'd
really need to be alerted that you
probably ought to not walk down the
street looking at your phone because you
never know what rebar hole you might
fall into I'm reminded actually of when
we were in Quito on our last study
abroad trip with 30 students and our two
children and we had to hub back to Quito
in Ecuador the Secretary's an incredibly
amazing and diverse country but it's got
really the the one big hub so we were
back in Quito middle the trip to do
laundry and to get to our next place and
we were standing at this intersection
that I feel like must have had like 17
streets coming out of it it was probably
only five or something right but we saw
this little kid like four years old
maybe maybe three like definitely
younger than five this little kid
come out of this building clutching some
bills and he navigates across like three
different streets with three different
lanes of traffic goes into a little
comedor
or no i'd like a tienda gets I don't
know some fruit maybe some bananas and
papayas comes back out navigates the
back and presumably goes back into his
apartment whereas mom or dad or someone
as is who's waiting on the fruit that
they sent him to get and we're sitting
there going wow we could barely trust
ourselves much less our children who
were far older than that kid to do that
on the other hand on the other hand at
that point we could trust our children
in
Amazon right because they had
experienced the Amazon where is this kid
in Quito probably had never been out of
Quito so it really is about your life
experience and most Americans have grown
up in a world where they have become
dependent on the invisible lawyers
who've made their world safe and so no
the beaches don't need to be closed down
people need [ __ ] grow up already yeah
if you've ever sat behind a really tall
lawyer in a movie though you know
they're not invisible
alright I want to just kiss you Bart
okay tomber I just want to cap this
discussion here this this discussion
obviously mirrors what we said one or
two livestreams ago about the epidemic
of learned helplessness that seems to
have taken over the world and we need to
bootstrap our way out of this so I don't
know I'm hoping the slogan has never
been said by anybody before but live at
your own risk that's my feeling is you
should live at your own risk and that I
want that's the title we should have had
for this episode leave at your own risk
alright well anyway that's a piece of
advice you heard it here first and
second and third now that we've said it
repeatedly yeah we just keep saying it
yep all right there's a paper out
suggesting that obesity is a significant
risk factor in in bad outcomes in both
hospitalizations and bad outcomes kovat
19 and I'm not going to spend a ton of
time on it here from the discussion
quote it is notable that the chronic
condition with the strongest association
with critical illness was obesity with
substantially higher odds ratio than any
cardiovascular or pulmonary disease
obesity is well recognized to be a
pro-inflammatory conditional so the
paper isn't perfect it's rough around
the edges not going to go into into
analysis like we did on the was this a
peer review paper or is this a preprint
paper this is a preprint paper okay yeah
this is a preprint paper just out there
was some journalistic reporting on it
including an article from Wired now
wired as I understand it as I remember
it used to be a reasonable publication
wasn't fully captured by the ridiculous
people just yet but here's what
they have to say quote obesity appears
to be one of the biggest risk factors
related to kovat 19 hospitalizations and
critical illness
Newsweek claimed on Tuesday yet this
rhetoric is based on flawed and limited
evidence which only exacerbates the
stigma that larger bodied people already
face in society in our healthcare system
that stigma is what truly jeopardizes
their health not weight itself a fact
that's only more important to consider
in the midst of this pandemic wait what
you know really that just speaks for
itself this I mean come on people
yeah this is making Wired magazine a
risk factor yes reading what reading
Wired magazine this you also heard this
here first reading Wired magazine turns
out to be correlated with being a
greater risk for coming down with over
19 so can i wrap this back up into the
the discussion lee yes of telomeres and
the magnetic force of the grave and all
of that it is important that we now
understand the way obesity is connected
to many pathologies including maybe in
particular this one but in general
there's something obvious about this
right to the extent that you are a
machine that functions in the world you
are subject to damage you are unlike
most of the things that we call machines
because you can repair yourself you can
you know your car can't replace a
ball-joint but you effectively can
replace most of your tissues but the
rate of replacement is matched to your
lifetime expectations of need and you
can accelerate damage in any one of
these tissues well the thing is obesity
isn't anybody's fault right you're built
for an environment where these resources
are not highly available and many of us
are built for seasonal environments
where it makes sense to stock resources
when they're plentiful for lean times
but the fact is every step that you make
the world has a cost based on what
you're carrying the wear and tear on
your joints maybe this is less obvious
but the wear and tear on your heart the
you know the extra force necessary to
perfuse a larger body is bound to have
negative consequences for these tissues
which have a fixed amount of repair that
they can go through our lifetime I
should say fixed is probably just
slightly too clean right it is it is set
at birth for most tissues there is
probably some flexibility but that
flexibility comes with a risk but never
mind a topic for another day so anyway
yes obesity seems to be an important
risk factor the good news is that is at
least in principle something that might
be under people's control although
obviously not on this time scale right
mom but this isn't the last time you're
going to face an infectious disease so
it's worth thinking about yeah good okay
one more one more point and then we'll
take a break before we go into the QA
and a few just logistics before we wrap
up but on the topics of politics and
polarization and the optics of protest
we have mostly probably all seen at this
point the protests that have been
happening in in Michigan and Nevada
in Virginia I think in Washington state
in our former hometown in Olympia and it
is it is becoming a mark of being on the
right that people are out there
objecting to shutdowns and I find this
alarming on so many levels among other
things all of us no matter our politics
and no matter our politics will be
having an increasingly difficult time
with being in lockdown
with not having access to our usual ways
being our usual in many cases income
streams ways to get out out and interact
with people all of this and if it
becomes a mark of being a conservative
or
or a Magus wearing supporter of Donald
Trump that you object and you talk
publicly about how difficult it is for
you and that not talking about it and
being stoic is what is your badge of
being a liberal or a Democrat we've got
really big problems this is I would say
really really really not the time to be
playing politics this could be unifying
us in fact so our leaders should be
allowing it to do so
that means for instance within the US
Trump should not be playing to his base
for points and Democrats shouldn't be
going apoplectic if or when Trump does
the right thing we all want and need to
win against this virus if that happens
if we play it will be played as a win by
our leaders whoever they are and
whatever they've done it's better that
our leaders get credit that they don't
deserve if they don't deserve it for a
good outcome and a crisis that they
botched then that those leaders go down
history is having overseen a massive
meltdown of social and economic order in
the wake of a devastating pandemic so
know enough already we need to stop the
polarization what if we become a society
in which those who are facemasks and flu
season are marked as liberals and those
who don't are conservatives we've we've
already seen what this the the Maggie
hat phenomenon in the last election sort
of revealed us as a Seussian landscape
of star bellied snitches and snitches
without it doesn't make any sense to
live that way the hatred and the
immediate judgment of people who look a
different way it's awful and serves
nobody but those who would rather that
we don't have a functioning society and
not figure out collectively how to make
a better world so just to finish here if
Donald Trump for instance were to start
being a statesman and I don't see any
evidence that that's happening but if he
were to start being a statesman and
fast-tracking the formulation and
distribution of tests both
antigen-antibody and to provide a
plausible measured prediction for when
social distancing measures could safely
Bea's based on those testing results
well if that were to happen all of us
all of us regardless of how we voted or
how we intend to vote in the future
should say yes ma'am well done good Anya
keep it up thank you
gratulations please keep that up and at
this rate it doesn't look like that's
going to happen which means he will be
less motivated to make it happen and we
are more doomed to about outcome those
are excellent points and I agree with
them and they dovetail with something
you and I have not talked about but I've
also been pondering the question of
politics in this era and the fact that
it is it is almost the precise
description of the opposite of what we
need and one thing I would just point
our audience to there is a tendency if
one says something critical of Trump or
his response to this crisis to regard
that statement as inherently political
and the same thing is true on the left
if if one says it is completely
unacceptable that the party that
supposedly represents my interests is
going to hand me Joe Biden as the right
solution to this moment in history the
right solution to challenge Donald Trump
I am NOT responding politically my point
is the fact that our two-party system
has delivered us Donald Trump and Joe
Biden says it is a failure and yes you
can tell me this is not the moment to
address that we have to simply deal with
the evil on the other side by voting for
the evil that we are you know delivering
you in the in the blue hue No if not now
when we have to deal with a system that
election after election delivers us
nothing but unacceptable choices and I'm
sorry if you're a trump supporter and
that comes as a shock to you that you
would think you know I would have to
admire him I don't I don't know why we
elected him on the other hand I can't
say that the alternative is vastly
better we're just basically choosing
every election between failure modes and
I'm sick of it
so let us sideline those people who
would delete bill over us such terrible
options and let's come together and
figure out what the hell we're supposed
to do with a system
where the parties have a stranglehold on
power and the answers they give us are
unacceptable yes good and regard each
other
fundamentally as human beings rather
than as Democrats or Republicans
liberals or conservatives you know
flyover country versus coastal elites
yeah it's it's it's inherently divisive
and just because you hear people
speaking in a political way most of the
time do not assume that when you hear
somebody making a critique of a
political entity that they are being
political I don't feel like we are I
feel like we are being patriotic not
just to our nation but to our planet I
think it's never been more obvious that
we have these levels of obligation and
yes nation is important but it's not the
only one and it's not the top one our
obligation to the future humans is
paramount and if we're going to get out
of this crisis and we're gonna get out
of the thing that creates crisis after
crisis we're gonna do so by thinking in
a non-political way it doesn't mean we
have to we can do anything other than
abide by the realities we're handed but
our objective should not be political
very good
all right all right just a couple
logistics we're gonna do with super chat
what we did last time I'm going to take
the first half hour of the next
livestream to go through the the that I
guess the top monetary value slash best
questions that we see in a very quick
look through and then the second half
hour to go through the lie of the super
check questions that come in during that
live chat during that livestream and
that'll start in 15 or so minutes after
we stop here and then we're going to
change up our schedule and it's been a
little inconsistent of late but we are
people seem to like when we ended up
having to drop into the weekend last
time so I think we're going to for a
little bit here shoot for Tuesday's at
this time Tuesdays at 3:30 Pacific and
then Saturdays at 12:30 at noon 30
Pacific which will allow people in
Europe to tune in live which we're
hearing some people want to do and I
would just add we are looking for
model to deal with things like question
superin chat is not ideal we're dealing
with it for now and we're learning how
to marshal it but we are open to a
better model and actively looking for
one so if you're not thrilled with the
super chat system you are not alone all
right we will see you in about 15
minutes